cuando trabajamos con los lentes
delgados vamos a tener que usar esta
fórmula 1 / efe igual a 1 / de ohl +1 /
day y esto no es difícil
excepto que necesitamos saber cuando son
positivos y cuando son negativos vamos a
descubrirlo
efe es la longitud del punto focal
cuando tenemos un lente delgado vamos a
tener un foco a cada lado de excelente
la longitud focal es la distancia que va
desde el centro del lente hasta uno de
estos puntos focales no importa cuál de
ellos sea y si queremos saber si efe es
positiva o negativa lo único que tenemos
que hacer es fijarnos en qué tipo de
lente tenemos en este caso tenemos un
lente convexo también conocido como
lente convergente y resulta que para
este tipo de lentes la longitud del
punto focal siempre siempre va a ser
positivo si esta longitud focal de aquí
fuera de 8 centímetros
aquí pondríamos ocho centímetros
positivo
y no importa cual foco elijamos la
longitud focal de aquí también va a ser
de ocho centímetros positivo y esto
siempre va a suceder si tenemos lentes
convergentes o convexos tenemos otro
tipo de lente y a este se le denomina
cóncavo o divergente si tenemos un lente
cóncavo o divergente
tendremos también dos focos uno a cada
lado del lente
estos se van a encontrar sobre este eje
a cierta distancia del centro del lente
y por definición la longitud focal en un
lente divergente o cóncavo siempre va a
ser negativa
si esta distancia fuera de 8 centímetros
en la fórmula la pondríamos como 8
centímetros
negativo por lo que solo tenemos que
fijarnos en el tipo de lente que tenemos
para saber si la longitud focal es
positiva o negativa de hoy y de ahí
pueden ser grandes pequeñas positivas o
negativas pueden ser de una imagen real
o una imagen virtual no importa sólo
tenemos que fijarnos en el tipo de lente
que tenemos para saber si vamos a poner
una longitud focal positiva o negativa
así que no hay tanto problema con esto
que pasa con de o de o representar la
distancia hacia el objeto tengo un
objeto por acá y siempre vamos a dibujar
los objetos como flechas para saber si
están al derecho o al revés la distancia
al objeto siempre se va a medir desde el
centro del lente hasta donde se
encuentra el objeto
esta es mi de hoy y este es aún más
fácil las distancias al objeto siempre
van a ser positivas si esto fuera de 30
centímetros en la fórmula siempre voy a
poner esta cantidad positiva 30
centímetros positivos si fueran 40
centímetros serían 40 centímetros
positivo siempre será positivo a menos
que tengamos una excepción que pueda
ocurrir cuando tenemos varios lentes
solamente en ese caso podríamos llegar a
tener una distancia al objeto negativa
pero si tenemos un solo lente la
distancia al objeto siempre va a ser
positiva no importa si el lentes cóncavo
y convexo la distancia del objeto cuando
hay un solo lente siempre va a ser
positiva
así que la distancia del objeto es más
fácil siempre va a ser positiva si
tenemos un solo lente y que hay con la
distancia a la imagen
esta puede ser un poquito más complicada
la distancia la imagen se refiere a la
distancia entre el lente y la imagen que
forma pero esta imagen puede estar a un
lado o al otro del lente imaginemos que
para este ejemplo terminamos con una
imagen que se encuentra aquí y de cabeza
esta es la imagen que se formó con este
objeto y este lente convergente la
distancia a la imagen se mide desde el
centro del lente hasta donde se forma la
imagen y siempre se mide paralela a este
eje principal
algunas personas se confunden y piensan
que debe medirse desde el centro hasta
aquí haciendo una línea diagonal pero no
es así
siempre la vamos a medir desde el centro
y paralelo al eje principal hasta donde
se forma la imagen ésta es la distancia
de la imagen y cuando vamos a saber si
esto es positivo o negativo aquí hay que
tener cuidado la distancia a la imagen
va a ser positiva si se encuentra del
lado opuesto a donde está el objeto otra
forma para recordar esto es que si están
usando bien este lente ustedes van a
estar usando el lente frente a su ojo
para observar el objeto si yo tengo mi
ojo aquí pues no me va a servir de nada
el lente pues mi ojo está viendo
directamente el objeto y el lente se
encuentra todavía más lejos no me sirve
de nada
pero si estoy usando el lente de la
forma correcta mi ojo va a estar de este
otro lado voy a estar observando al
objeto a través del lente y no es que de
mi ojo salgan rayos de luz simplemente
voy a estar observando al objeto a
través del lente y de hecho no veré el
objeto sino su imagen que se está
proyectando aquí de cabeza y vamos a
tener esta distancia a la imagen
positiva si es que se va a formar el
mismo lado que está nuestro ojo en este
caso está a la derecha del lente pero lo
importante es que esta imagen se forme
del lado opuesto al que está el objeto y
del mismo lado en donde tenemos nuestro
ojo y eso se cumple sin importar que
tengamos un lente cóncavo como lente
convexo un lente convergente o un lente
divergente si la imagen se encuentra del
mismo lado en donde está nuestro ojo
entonces la distancia a la imagen es
positiva a lo mejor en este caso
divergente la imagen termina formándose
de este lado
nuevamente la distancia a la imagen se
mide desde el centro del lente hasta
donde se forma la imagen y en este caso
mi ojo sigue estando de este otro lado
ya que yo debo estar observando el
objeto a través del lente
y veo esta imagen porque se encuentra
del lado opuesto esta imagen se
encuentra del lado opuesto a donde está
mi ojo u otra forma de verlo es que se
encuentra del mismo lado en donde se
encuentra el objeto en este caso
tendremos una distancia a la imagen
negativa tendré que ponerla en la
fórmula con signo negativo o si obtengo
una cantidad negativa en esta fórmula
parada y voy a saber que esta imagen se
está formando del lado opuesto del lente
a dónde está mi ojo estas son las
convenciones de los signos para la
distancia a la imagen pero noten que
esta fórmula sólo me está dando la
distancia horizontal hacia estos puntos
no me dice nada sobre qué tan alta será
la imagen o qué tan alto es el objeto si
quiero conocer esas alturas tengo que
usar una fórmula diferente esta otra
fórmula es la de magnificación o aumento
está fórmula nos dice que el aumento o
magnificación m es igual a menos la
distancia a la imagen
y la distancia al objeto y aquí notamos
algo si la distancia a la imagen resulta
negativa tendremos el negativo de otro
número negativo la distancia al objeto
siempre es positiva por lo que el
negativo de un negativo siempre va a ser
positivo si nuestra distancia a la
imagen resulta negativa como en este
caso entonces tendremos un aumento o
magnificación positivo y eso significa
que tendremos una imagen al derecho y si
la distancia a la imagen resulta
positiva como en este caso entonces
nuestro aumento o magnificación va a ser
negativo esto nos indica que la imagen
va a estar volteada o de cabeza así que
es importante conocer si nuestra
distancia a la imagen resulta positiva o
negativa porque la distancia a la imagen
negativa significa que no va a estar
invertida y la distancia a la imagen
positiva significa que esta imagen va a
estar invertida o de cabeza veamos
algunos ejemplos de esto
tenemos este ejemplo y nos dicen
encuentra la distancia a la imagen
tenemos este diagrama y vamos a usar
nuestra fórmula del lente delgado tengo
que ver cuál es el valor de f efe es la
longitud focal y tenemos estos dos focos
cuya longitud focal es de 8 centímetros
serán ocho centímetros positivo y ocho
centímetros negativo recordemos que la
regla es fijarnos en el tipo de lente
que tenemos en este caso tengo un lente
cóncavo también conocido como lente
divergente y con esto yo sé que mi
distancia focal va a ser negativa así
que aquí tengo uno entre menos ocho
centímetros esto es igual a uno entre la
distancia del objeto y la distancia al
objeto es aquí tengo 24 centímetros y
eso será positivo o negativo ya que aquí
tengo solo un lente quiere decir que mi
distancia al objeto siempre va a ser
positiva aquí es 1 entre 24 centímetros
y ahora podemos despejar la distancia de
la imagen y si uso algo de álgebra me va
a quedar uno
entre menos ocho centímetros menos uno
entre 24 centímetros y no tengo que esto
puede estar en centímetros o en metros
no importa qué unidades usemos aquí solo
tengo que asegurarme de que estas
unidades sean consistentes
si yo resuelvo esto me queda que del
lado izquierdo hay menos uno entre seis
centímetros y esto es igual no a day
sino a uno entre day y ahora voy a tener
el inverso en ambos lados y me va a
quedar que day es igual a menos seis
centímetros y que significa que de ahí
sea igual a menos seis centímetros
significa que mi imagen va a estar a
seis centímetros del lente y el signo
negativo significa que se va a encontrar
del otro lado de donde está mi ojo del
mismo lado del objeto si mi ojo está
aquí y estoy usando correctamente el
lente voy a usar el lente para ver a
través de él el objeto la imagen que se
forma va a estar de este otro lado del
lente
6 centímetros de donde todo lo vamos a
medir a partir del centro del lente así
que va a estar a 6 centímetros del
centro del lente esto está sobre mi eje
principal por lo que mi imagen va a
estar por aquí pero esto no me dice que
tan alta va a estar mi imagen aunque si
nos dice si esta imagen está invertida o
no la distancia a la imagen es negativa
recuerda nuestra regla las distancias a
la imagen que son negativas nos indican
que van a estar hacia arriba no van a
estar invertidas lo que sigo sin saber
es qué tan alta va a ser para esto tengo
que usar la ecuación del aumento o la
magnificación la magnificación es igual
a menos de iu / d o esto es menos cuánto
fue mide y pues es menos 6
aquí pongo menos 6 centímetros y aquí
abajo pongo 24 centímetros que fue mi
distancia hacia el objeto qué es lo que
me da este menos se cancela con este
menos por lo que me queda un cuarto
positivo y recordemos que los aumentos o
magnificaciones positivas indican que la
imagen se encuentra derecha y un cuarto
significa que mi imagen va a tener una
cuarta parte de la altura del objeto es
decir si mi objeto tuviera ocho
centímetros de altura mi imagen sería de
dos centímetros de altura así que aquí
dibujo una imagen que está derecha
porque esto fue positivo y es una cuarta
parte del tamaño de la original más o
menos por aquí no va a estar invertida y
es una cuarta parte del objeto original
y esto es lo que voy a observar con mi
ojo a través de excelente y este es un
ejemplo del uso de esta fórmula del
lente delgado y también de la ecuación
del aumento o magnificación